hello and welcome to these sixth part in
the tutorial series of machine learning
applied to stocks and Forex where we
left off we were making this pattern
finder basically and we printed it out
but we're not actually saving the
pattern or anything so now what we
actually want to do is begin saving this
pattern so what we want to do is come up
here and create an empty global array
and actually to empty global arrays
first one we want is pattern a our four
pattern array
that'll be empty for now and what this
is going to do is as we run pattern
finder every pattern will get stored
into the pattern or write subsequently
the next thing we're gonna do is create
a performance array and everything
well after we as we make this pattern
while we're making this pattern we
actually we didn't save it to a variable
but we will we stored the outcome right
which was an average of in the future in
the next twenty to thirty points what
was the average price at the time and so
we're calling that the outcome right so
we're also going to store that to the
performance array and in these two
arrays each each value in the array will
have the same index number as its as its
partner now you might think well why
aren't we making a dictionary out of
this and it would have been nice to make
a dictionary or you can make like a
multi-dimensional array or something
otherwise known as a dictionary and
usually but the issue is with the
dictionary what we really needed was the
key to be the pattern array because what
we're gonna do is we're gonna we find a
pattern we find a similar pattern and
then we wanted to compare that pattern
and see what the outcomes were but the
issue was you can't have an array as the
key and if you have no idea what a
dictionary is don't worry about it I
guess but for anybody that does know
what a dictionary is probably wondering
why we're not doing that so you can have
an array as the key to the dictionary it
would have to be the performance value
but you can't this is the kicker you
can't have an identical key in the
dictionary right you can have identical
values right you could have
different keys equal the same thing but
you can't have identical keys so when
you sit when you go to define that key
you would overwrite the most like the
other key and the problem with this is
you would be overriding possibly better
results like a more accurate pattern
might end up getting more overwritten
anyway it would be a huge mistake to do
it so we're not gonna do that we're just
gonna make two arrays so anyway so
that's that so those will be empty for
now and then what we need to do is come
down into our patterns storage here or I
mean our pattern finder rather and in
fact we should change this name to
storage because actually soon we'll
actually make a pattern finder and
that'll make more sense to call it
pattern finder so I'll say this is
pattern storage that's what it's doing
is it's storing patterns now the next
thing that we want to do is well that
would be kind of useful is up here well
it's hmm I can't decide if I want to do
it or not but usually in something like
this like in a machine learning type of
script or a script that's doing a lot of
calculations you want to have processing
time so we'll just say a hat start time
equals time time so that will store
whatever time it is currently and then
at the very end of this script basically
we'll just come down well first of all
we don't need this anymore and then
we'll come down here one tab over nth
time will be also time time let's say it
and see pet start time pet in time okay
and then and then at the end we'll
subtract the two and then then you can
find out how long the storage of
patterns so this way you can start to
find inefficiencies in your script now
the next thing we might want to do is
we'll change this from a print and we'll
call this average outcome and we should
also in case this and try and accept
just in case and I'll talk about that in
a second the reason why we're going to
want to do this
is with our person we're going to be
doing a percent change of a percent
change and so this can give us
especially well I won't get into the
maths but well you can wind up with a
negative infinity percent change so
anyway what we're going to want to do is
accept exception E and then print string
E just in case we've type out or
something and then also the if if this
does happen we'll just say the average
outcome is zero but just throw that in
and try and accept your stick just to
keep ourselves saying here now what we
want to do is remember how this
basically the average outcome created a
number right it said with the digit of
that outcome was well that's no good
right we need it to actually be a
percent change as well right so so again
we need to normalize everything so again
probably this is the most accurate
representation of using percent change
or a logarithm
but anyway so now we'll do future
outcome equals and our lovely percent
change formula will come into play here
and that's gonna be current point
average outcome now with that keep in
mind the average outcome can be zero so
that gives us a possibility of a
division by zero and also all kinds of
interesting stuff so the other thing we
want to do is also consider the fact if
like let's let's let's just let's run
this round so let's save and this is our
start point and this is our ending point
right so what if we went from negative
10 to 10 right this is saying that if we
start from negative 10 and we go to 10
we went to we did negative 200 no that's
not right right but the problem is we're
dividing by a negative 10 and that
division is actually meant to be
something that kind of sizes the
equation if you
break down how the percent change
formula works so really what we want to
do is come over to our percent change
formula here and instead of dividing by
start point overall we actually just
need to divide by the absolute value of
start point so we'll save that and let's
run that again and let me drag this back
over again and now if we do percent
change let's we want to confirm that 10
to 20 works what if we did 10 to
negative 20 negative 300 but what if we
did so that that also still works if the
negative is on the other side of the
equation but what if we did negative 10
to 20 and that works as well so positive
300 negative 300 100 so everything still
works
you just need those absolute value bars
or just well absolute value parentheses
in this case but it's basically what you
know absolute value bars does and
written that so we need that there as
well because we will have percent change
using a negative negative numbers when
we compare well not only future outcome
can have it but then also when we're
start comparing formula or comparing
patterns we're going to see it a lot now
the next thing we want is no longer do
we need to print all of this out there's
not really much point to it will keep
the make sure you keep the y plus equals
1 though now the next thing we need to
do is if we go we need to append the
pattern to this pattern array but also
we need something that's like pattern
right so Wow why is less than X where we
start with an empty you know pattern
alright and then what we need to do is
just copy this program come down here
and what we need to do is pattern dot
append and we need to start appending
all this pattern you obviously need to
append it in the row in the order right
so pattern pen people I'm and then we'll
go ahead and in fact I'm just going to
delete this comment and stuff
just to leave that pattern pampy one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
and now let's fix this two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so now
we've got a pattern appended one to ten
so it made an array so this pattern is
now an array of percent changes and now
all we need to do is do pattern array so
the array of patterns basically we want
to append pattern subsequently
performance array we want to append that
future outcome then y plus equals one
let me bring this up a little bit and
separate those just for ease of reading
now we've got Pat end time is time time
cool so just to make sure we've done
everything these lengths ought to be the
same so we'll print the length of
pattern array print the length of
performance array and then also we want
to print the time it took to store these
patterns so print pattern storage took
and then we do I already forgot what we
said
it'll be Pat end time - Pat start time
so Pat and time - Pat start time seconds
okay cool so we'll save that and let's
run this and make sure we are indeed
storing patterns and it will only store
all of the patterns found in one day but
I believe that was already like I forget
how long that this file is but it's a
pretty long file so should have quite a
few patterns let's run that no syntax
errors yet but let's see what else I
think we changed the name of what
patterns storage now yes so we'll run
pattern store it go ahead and type store
it
global name future who come so future
outcome fix that typo front of the game
[Music]
up alt P for the last thing let me tight
run it seems like it might be running
this time okay cool so we found 60 1971
patterns 16 1971 outcomes to those
patterns and the storage of all of those
patterns and really the time it took to
run through this entire file took to two
point one two seconds so if you were to
use fresh data and run through the month
right that would be 30 days we take
about a minute in theory to do it all
but probably actually a little bit less
but we can talk about that later
so anyways sure enough looks like we've
stored all of these patterns we've done
it successfully so cool so our pattern
storage works and actually we could we
could test this and say pattern array 5
right so we see ok so this is the
pattern of percent change in rate 5 and
then pattern our performance arrays what
we want the performance array 5 what was
the outcome of that array and it's a
positive move so that would be a
positive already so that's gonna
conclude this video on the pattern
storage function here in the next video
what we're going to be doing is creating
our pattern recognition so we're going
to look through well we're gonna store
all the patterns we're gonna find the
most recent pattern and then we're gonna
find previous patterns that are very
similar to the current pattern so I'm
going to make another function and it's
gonna be our pattern our actual pattern
recognition function so anyway hopefully
that sounds interesting to you guys as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support the subscriptions and until
next